today I announce that ineligible
households where all adults are working
at least 16 hours we will introduce 30
hours of free child care not just for
three and four-year-olds but for every
single child over the age of nine months
[Applause]
eternity leave ends it's a package worth
on average six and a half thousand
pounds every year for a family with a
two-year-old child using 35 hours of
child care every week and reduces their
child care costs by nearly 60 percent
[Applause]
sure there is enough Supply in the
market
working parents of two-year-olds will be
able to access 15 hours of free care
from April 2024 helping around half a
million parents
from September 24 that 15 hours will be
extended to all children from nine
months up meaning a total of nearly 1
million parents will be eligible
and from September 25 every single
working parent of under fives will have
access to 30 hours free child care per
week